- Selamat datang semula ke "Memahami Maklumat dan Pengiraan Kuantum." Nama saya John Watrous, dan saya adalah Pengarah Teknikal untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran kelima dalam siri ini, dan ia adalah pelajaran pertama dalam unit kedua siri ini, yang berkaitan dengan Algoritma Kuantum.
Dalam unit ini, kita akan mengkaji kelebihan pengiraan maklumat kuantum, iaitu, kita akan tengok apa yang boleh kita buat
dengan komputer kuantum dan kelebihan yang mungkin ada pada komputer kuantum berbanding komputer klasik.
Kita akan fokus pada apa yang boleh kita buat dengan satu komputer kuantum berbanding dengan setting teragih, contohnya,
di mana beberapa komputer kuantum berinteraksi melalui sejenis rangkaian.
Memang ada kelebihan kuantum yang boleh dijumpai dalam setting teragih, di mana komunikasi dan kriptografi memainkan peranan,
tapi kita tak akan bincang benda-benda tu dalam unit ini.
Unit ini berkaitan dengan algoritma kuantum yang berjalan pada satu komputer kuantum.
Jom mulakan dengan soalan yang natural. Apa kelebihan yang mungkin ada pada komputer kuantum?
Yang utama ialah komputer kuantum mungkin boleh memberikan penyelesaian yang lebih laju untuk sesetengah masalah pengiraan.
Masa itu berharga, dan walaupun komputer yang kita guna setiap hari agak laju, ia masih terlalu perlahan
untuk menyelesaikan masalah pengiraan tertentu semata-mata kerana kesukaran pengiraan yang wujud dalam masalah-masalah tu.
Potensi bahawa komputer kuantum mungkin boleh biarkan kita selesaikan masalah yang komputer klasik terlalu perlahan untuk diselesaikan
itulah sebenarnya yang mendorong penyelidikan algoritma kuantum selama beberapa dekad yang lalu.
Ada sumber pengiraan lain selain masa yang boleh dipertimbangkan, seperti jumlah memori komputer yang diperlukan untuk pengiraan,
tapi komputer kuantum tak boleh jimat banyak dari segi memori, rupanya, dan memori komputer klasik agak murah
terutamanya berbanding dengan memori kuantum. Jadi memang tak banyak harapan di sini.
Kita juga boleh fikirkan sumber lain seperti jumlah tenaga yang diperlukan untuk pengiraan, tapi sebenarnya kita tak perlukan banyak tenaga pun
untuk mengira secara klasik, terutamanya kalau kita sanggup perlahan sikit.
Jadi memang masa yang diperlukan untuk pengiraan itulah fokus utama kita.
Ini adalah gambaran keseluruhan untuk pelajaran ini, yang berkaitan dengan model pengiraan tertentu yang dikenali sebagai model query.
Kita boleh anggap model ini seperti piring Petri untuk mengembangkan idea algoritma, sama ada kuantum atau klasik.
Ia bukan model praktikal yang menggambarkan jenis masalah pengiraan yang kita hadapi dalam kehidupan nyata.
Kita akan beralih dari model query dalam pelajaran seterusnya unit ini dan fokus kepada model yang didorong oleh konsep pengiraan yang lebih praktikal,
tapi model query adalah tempat yang sangat bagus untuk bermula.
Ia adalah model yang mudah yang membolehkan kita meneroka potensi komputer kuantum tanpa banyak butiran teknikal yang menghalang,
dan ia juga membolehkan kita mengasingkan beberapa idea penting di sebalik pengiraan kuantum dan cara ia berfungsi.
Pengiraan kuantum memang mula berkembang dalam model ini, dan idea-idea yang dibangunkan di dalamnya secara langsung menginspirasi algoritma kuantum yang penting
seperti algoritma Shor untuk pemfaktoran.
Dalam bahagian pertama pelajaran ini, kita akan tengok secara khusus apa itu model query pengiraan,
dan dalam bahagian kedua, ketiga, dan keempat, kita akan bincang tiga algoritma query kuantum, iaitu algoritma Deutsch,
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, dan algoritma Simon, yang mendedahkan kelebihan yang semakin mengesankan
komputer kuantum berbanding komputer klasik dalam model query pengiraan.
Untuk menerangkan model query pengiraan, jom kita mulakan dengan abstraksi pengiraan yang lebih standard.
Ini adalah gambar yang menggambarkan pengiraan dalam istilah yang sangat mudah dan asas.
Kita ada input, yang biasanya berbentuk rentetan binari, walaupun kita boleh guna simbol lain kalau kita nak.
Input diberikan kepada pengiraan, yang diwakili oleh segi empat tepat biru dalam gambar ini,
dan hasil pengiraan ialah output yang dihasilkan, dan sekali lagi, itu paling kerap adalah rentetan binari.
Sudah tentu, gambar ini langsung tak spesifik tentang bagaimana pengiraan itu sendiri berfungsi.
Kita boleh merumuskan model pengiraan khusus yang berbeza untuk buat benda tu, seperti mesin Turing dan circuit Boolean,
atau circuit kuantum kalau kita fikir tentang pengiraan kuantum.
Memang betul bahawa gambar ini tak menggambarkan fakta bahawa banyak komputer yang kita guna setiap hari sentiasa menerima input dan menghasilkan output,
pada dasarnya berinteraksi dengan kita dan dengan komputer lain melalui internet, contohnya.
Tapi kita tak cuba nak gambarkan interaksi-interaksi tu di sini.
Ini adalah tentang pemodelan tugas pengiraan yang terpencil.
Contohnya, input mungkin adalah pengekodan binari nombor atau perwakilan matriks
WEBVTT
atau penerangan molekul atau apa sahaja yang kita ada dalam fikiran, dan ada beberapa tugas pengiraan
yang dilakukan pada input sahaja.
Perkara utama di sini ialah keseluruhan input diberikan kepada pengiraan, dan tiada apa pun tentang input yang tersembunyi daripadanya.
Model query pengiraan berfungsi secara berbeza.
Dalam model query, input disediakan dalam bentuk fungsi yang boleh diakses oleh pengiraan dengan membuat query,
atau dengan kata lain, dengan menilai fungsi pada input yang berbeza.
Di sini kita boleh lihat ia diwakili dalam bentuk gambar.
Sama seperti yang kita ada sebelum ini, pengiraan diwakili oleh segi empat tepat biru, tapi bukannya menerima input secara terus
dalam bentuk rentetan bit, contohnya, ia mengakses input dengan berkesan bertanya soalan dan menerima jawapan.
Kita kadang-kadang guna istilah oracle dan kotak hitam untuk merujuk kepada mekanisme yang menyediakan input.
Ada perbezaan antara oracle dan kotak hitam dalam teori kerumitan, tapi itu langsung tak relevan untuk tujuan perbincangan ini.
Pokoknya, istilah-istilah ini bertujuan untuk menyampaikan idea asas.
Dalam Yunani purba, kita boleh pergi ke oracle, seperti Oracle di Delphi, dan bertanya soalan penting,
dan oracle akan menjawab soalan khusus tu, tapi dia tentunya tak akan beritahu semua yang dia tahu.
Seiring dengan itu, bila kita fikir tentang kotak hitam, kita bayangkan sejenis proses atau sistem
di mana kita boleh pilih apa yang masuk dan kita boleh tengok apa yang keluar, tapi kita tak faham cara dalaman ia berfungsi.
Dan itulah keadaannya di sini. Input kepada masalah berbentuk fungsi, dan semua yang boleh kita buat adalah menilai fungsi tu,
tapi selain tu, kita tak ada pengetahuan atau pemahaman tentang cara ia berfungsi.
Sepanjang pelajaran ini, kita akan guna huruf f untuk fungsi yang mewakili input, dan kita akan buat andaian
bahawa ia sentiasa berbentuk seperti yang kita tengok di sini.
Sigma merujuk kepada abjad binari, jadi f adalah fungsi dari rentetan bit ke rentetan bit,
dan khususnya, kita akan anggap bahawa input kepada f adalah rentetan bit yang panjangnya n, dan outputnya adalah rentetan bit yang panjangnya m,
di mana n dan m adalah integer positif.
Untuk masalah yang berbeza, kita akan ada sekatan pada n dan m, tapi dalam semua kes, fungsi input akan berbentuk seperti ini.
Bila kita kata pengiraan membuat query, apa yang kita maksudkan ialah fungsi f dinilai sekali,
iaitu, beberapa rentetan x yang panjangnya N dipilih oleh pengiraan, dan rentetan f of x kemudian disediakan kepadanya
oleh oracle atau kotak hitam. Dan akhirnya, cara yang sangat mudah kita ukur kos pengiraan
sebuah algoritma query adalah dengan mengira berapa banyak query yang diperlukan.
Jadi, walaupun memang betul bahawa kita paling berminat tentang berapa lama pengiraan mengambil masa, bila kita kaji model query,
kita biasanya biarkan benda-benda mudah dan hanya kira query, dan itulah yang akan kita buat dalam pelajaran ini.
Sekarang, jom kita tengok beberapa contoh masalah query, iaitu masalah pengiraan dalam model query,
dan di sini, by the way, saya hanya akan huraikan masalah-masalah itu sendiri, dan pada ketika ini, saya tak akan cakap apa-apa tentang cara menyelesaikannya.
Masalah pertama adalah masalah OR.
Dalam kes ini, input adalah fungsi dari n bit kepada hanya 1 bit, jadi m bersamaan dengan 1 untuk masalah ini,
dan output yang diperlukan untuk masalah tu adalah sama ada 1 atau 0.
Kalau ada rentetan n bit x yang mana f of x bersamaan dengan 1, maka jawapan yang betul adalah 1,
dan kalau tidak, jika f of x sentiasa 0 untuk setiap rentetan x, maka jawapan yang betul adalah 0.
Jadi kalau kita fikir tentang fungsi f sebagai memberi kita akses rawak kepada dua hingga n bit, satu untuk setiap rentetan n bit x,
maka apa yang ia tanya adalah OR bit-bit tu, dan itulah sebabnya ia dipanggil masalah OR.
Contoh lain adalah masalah pariti, yang serupa dengan masalah OR kecuali ia meminta pariti,
atau dengan kata lain, XOR eksklusif semua nilai output satu-bit fungsi itu.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah jawapan yang betul adalah 0 jika bilangan rentetan n bit x yang mana f of x bersamaan dengan 1 adalah genap,
dan jawapan yang betul adalah 1 jika nombor tu adalah ganjil.
Contoh masalah di mana m tidak semestinya bersamaan dengan 1 ialah masalah minimum.
Di sini, fungsi f mengambil bentuk biasa, dan tiada sekatan pada n dan m,
dan jawapan yang betul adalah nilai output fungsi yang mana-mana yang datang pertama dalam urutan leksikografi atau kamus
rentetan binari. Atau pun, kalau kita nak fikir tentang rentetan panjang m sebagai mewakili integer bukan negatif dalam notasi binari,
maka jawapan yang betul adalah nilai terkecil atau minimum yang keluar dari fungsi ini.
WEBVTT
Kadang-kadang kita juga mempertimbangkan masalah query di mana kita ada janji pada fungsi input, atau dengan kata lain, sejenis jaminan padanya,
dan kita tak risau tentang fungsi yang tak memenuhi janji tu.
Fungsi yang tak memenuhi janji dianggap sebagai input "tak kisah".
Dan kita tak bertanggungjawab untuk apa yang berlaku pada input-input tu.
Ini adalah contoh masalah query dengan janji yang dipanggil carian unik.
Ia berkaitan dengan masalah OR, tapi ia berbeza.
Fungsi input mempunyai bentuk yang sama seperti masalah OR, iaitu ia mengambil rentetan n bit kepada bit.
Kali ini, kita dijanjikan bahawa ada tepat satu rentetan Z yang menyebabkan f menilai kepada 1,
dengan f of x bersamaan dengan 0 untuk setiap rentetan x selain z, dan output yang betul adalah rentetan unik z ini.
Sudah tentu, ada pilihan untuk fungsi f yang tak memenuhi syarat ini, tapi kita tak letak sebarang keperluan langsung
pada algoritma untuk masalah ini bila ia diberikan fungsi-fungsi seperti itu sebagai input.
Kita hanya ambil kisah tentang fungsi yang memenuhi janji.
Sekarang, kesemua empat masalah yang saya sebut tadi adalah masalah yang cukup natural, iaitu mudah untuk menerangkannya,
dan mudah untuk bayangkan situasi di mana keperluan untuk menyelesaikannya mungkin timbul, tapi sesetengah masalah query tak begitu.
Malah, kadang-kadang kita mempertimbangkan masalah query yang sangat direka-reka, di mana susah nak bayangkan ada sesiapa yang pernah nak selesaikannya.
Masalah Simon, yang akan kita tengok kemudian dalam pelajaran ini, agak tergolong dalam kategori ini, tapi ada masalah lain
yang lebih teruk dalam erti kata tertentu, tapi ia, bagaimanapun, sebenarnya cukup penting untuk kajian model query.
Kita tak kaji masalah-masalah ini sebab kita semestinya nak selesaikannya dalam praktik.
Cara kita boleh fikirkannya ialah kita mencari ekstrem pelbagai jenis,
khususnya, bila kita bekerja dalam piring Petri model ini, cara natural untuk meneroka idea algoritma kuantum
ialah merumuskan masalah yang sangat direka-reka, di mana kita boleh mengeksploitasi sepenuhnya kuasa komputer kuantum.
Dan ini sebenarnya boleh memberi banyak pencerahan tentang bagaimana komputer kuantum berpotensi berguna dalam setting yang lebih praktikal.
Kita boleh formalkan konsep query dengan cara yang berbeza bergantung pada model pengiraan yang kita gunakan.
Contohnya, dalam model mesin Turing untuk pengiraan, yang tak pernah kita bincang dan kita tak akan masuk dalam siri ini,
ada cara tertentu untuk memformalkan konsep query yang masuk akal untuk model tu.
Untuk model circuit, kita takrifkan jenis gate khas yang dipanggil gate query, dan itulah cara query diwakili secara formal.
Untuk circuit Boolean, ada cara yang sangat mudah untuk buat ni, iaitu dengan membayangkan bahawa kita ada gate query
yang menilai fungsi input secara terus, seperti yang kita boleh lihat di skrin.
Ideanya ialah kita boleh guna gate query ini untuk membina circuit yang menyelesaikan masalah yang kita nak selesaikan,
dan agar berfungsi dengan betul, circuit tu kena beri jawapan yang betul untuk apa sahaja fungsi input f yang diberikan,
dengan mengandaikan ia memenuhi janji dalam kes masalah janji.
Ini adalah contoh mudah circuit Boolean yang menyelesaikan masalah pariti bila n bersamaan dengan 1,
jadi fungsi input f adalah dari 1 bit ke 1 bit dalam kes ini.
Apa yang circuit ini buat ialah menilai fungsi f pada input 0 dan 1 menggunakan dua gate query ini.
Kemudian ia masukkan dua nilai output yang ia dapat dari gate query ke dalam circuit Boolean dari pelajaran tiga yang mengira XOR,
yang sama dengan pariti.
Jelasnya, dua nilai input di sini bukan input kepada masalah, iaitu masalah pariti,
bila kita bekerja dengan model query, input kepada masalah adalah fungsi f, dan kita patut fikir tentang dua input ke dalam circuit ini
sebagai nilai yang dikodkan keras yang tak pernah berubah, ia pada dasarnya sebahagian daripada algoritma.
Kita nak kira XOR f 0 dan f 1, jadi kita mulakan dua wayar ini dengan cara ini
untuk biarkan ia berfungsi. Kita dah guna dua gate query di sini, yang ini dan yang ini,
jadi algoritma yang diwakili oleh circuit Boolean ini membuat dua query, dan kalau kita fikir tentang masalah pariti sebentar
untuk fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit, kita nampak bahawa ia memang perlu untuk mana-mana circuit Boolean yang menyelesaikan masalah ini
untuk membuat sekurang-kurangnya dua query.
Kalau kita hanya buat satu query supaya kita hanya tahu satu nilai output fungsi f dan bukan yang lain, kita sebenarnya langsung tak ada maklumat
tentang pariti, sebab nilai output lain boleh jadi sama ada 0 atau 1, yang membawa kepada salah satu daripada dua penyelesaian yang mungkin
kepada masalah tu. Jadi dari segi bilangan query yang dibuat, circuit Boolean ini sebaik yang boleh
untuk masalah pariti bila n bersamaan dengan 1.
WEBVTT
Ada satu lagi perkara tentang gate query yang patut disebut sebelum kita teruskan, iaitu bila kita mereka bentuk dan menganalisis algoritma query,
kita langsung tak risau tentang bagaimana gate query dilaksanakan.
Dianggap bahawa gate query ini diberikan kepada kita, dan kesukaran membinanya bukan urusan kita.
Kita boleh fikir gate query itu sendiri sebagai input kalau nak, dan bukan kerja kita untuk cipta input, kita hanya cuba menyelesaikan masalah tertentu
berdasarkan input. Sudah tentu, bila f adalah fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit, hanya ada empat pilihan yang mungkin,
dan ia mudah sahaja nak melaksanakan mana-mana satunya, tapi secara umum, untuk fungsi dengan banyak bit input,
ia mungkin sangat sukar untuk melaksanakan gate query bagi fungsi-fungsi tu.
Jelasnya, ini bukan bermakna isu bagaimana gate query dilaksanakan tak penting, sebaliknya ia tak dianggap
sebagai sebahagian daripada kos algoritma query.
Ini konsisten dengan idea bahawa ini bukan benar-benar tentang pengiraan praktikal atau sebenar-benar membina circuit,
ia tentang bekerja dalam rangka kerja teori yang memberitahu kita perkara menarik tentang pengiraan.
Kita akan ada lebih banyak benda nak cakap tentang ni bila kita buat lompatan dari model ini ke model pengiraan yang lebih standard, dan itulah yang terutamanya akan dibincangkan dalam pelajaran seterusnya,
Pelajaran 6.
Sekarang jom kita beralih perhatian kepada circuit kuantum.
Untuk circuit kuantum, kita akan tukar definisi gate query untuk menjadikannya unitari.
Kita nak boleh buat query dalam circuit kuantum dan agar ia beroperasi secara linear pada keadaan kuantum
supaya kita boleh buat query dalam superposisi secara berkesan.
Nampaknya macam kita ubah tiang gol, kalau boleh dikatakan, dengan menukar apa yang kita maksudkan dengan query berbanding dengan apa yang kita baru tengok untuk circuit Boolean,
tapi ada justifikasi untuknya yang akan kita bincang dengan lebih terperinci dalam pelajaran seterusnya.
Buat masa ni, ia hanya definisi sahaja.
Khususnya, definisinya adalah seperti berikut, diberikan mana-mana fungsi f yang berbentuk sama seperti sebelum ini,
iaitu ia memetakan rentetan n bit kepada rentetan m bit, gate query Uf bertindak ke atas n + m qubit
dan ditakrifkan oleh tindakan yang diterangkan di sini pada keadaan asas standard.
Kita akan tengok rajah yang mewakili definisi ini sebentar lagi, tapi pertama, biarkan saya jelaskan notasi yang digunakan di sini,
iaitu bila kita guna simbol untuk XOR sebagai operasi antara dua rentetan yang sama panjang,
kita merujuk kepada XOR eksklusif bitwise, dan di sini kita boleh tengok contohnya.
Dalam definisi, kita ada bahawa kedua-dua y dan f of x adalah rentetan panjang m, jadi rentetan di sini mewakili rentetan yang kita dapat
dengan meng-XOR dua rentetan tu bersama-sama, satu bit pada satu masa, dan ini adalah rajah yang menerangkan bagaimana gate-gate ini berfungsi.
N qubit teratas sepadan dengan argumen fungsi.
Dan bila ia bermula dalam keadaan asas standard, cat x dalam rajah ini, keadaan asas standard itu melalui tanpa perubahan
dan digemakan sebagai sebahagian daripada output.
M qubit terbawah sepadan dengan output fungsi f, dan bila ia bermula dalam mana-mana keadaan asas standard,
cat y dalam rajah ini, apa yang berlaku ialah output fungsi f of x di-XOR-kan pada rentetan y.
Inilah yang berlaku untuk keadaan asas standard, dan kalau kita nak tahu apa yang berlaku secara umum untuk keadaan kuantum lain, kita guna kelinearan, seperti yang selalu kita buat.
Sebab untuk takrifkan gate query seperti ini di mana kita gemakan input dan kita guna XOR bitwise untuk output
ialah gate-gate ini sentiasa unitari untuk mana-mana pilihan fungsi f.
Ini adalah, sebenarnya, operasi yang deterministik.
Dan kalau kita nak nyatakannya sebagai matriks untuk mana-mana pilihan fungsi F, kita akan dapat matriks permutasi,
iaitu yang ada satu dalam setiap baris dan setiap lajur, dan semua entri lain bersamaan dengan 0.
Dan matriks permutasi sentiasa unitari.
Malah, untuk operasi ini, kita akan dapat bahawa operasi itu adalah inversnya sendiri, jadi Uf dager bersamaan dengan Uf.
Kalau semua yang kita nak buat dengan gate-gate ini adalah menilai f of x untuk beberapa rentetan x, itu mudah,
kita boleh set y kepada rentetan semua-sifar. Jadi bila kita ambil XOR eksklusif bit y, kita dapat hanya f of x.
Di sini, by the way, kita boleh tengok notasi yang digunakan untuk menandakan rentetan semua-sifar.
Ia nampak seperti 0 pangkat M, tapi bukan itu maksudnya.
Ia bermaksud rentetan sifar yang panjangnya bersamaan dengan M.
Bila kita bercakap tentang rentetan berbanding nombor, eksponen biasanya bermaksud kita ulang rentetan tu beberapa kali,
jadi ini adalah 0 diulang m kali.
WEBVTT
Ia hanya cara yang mudah dan tepat untuk menerangkan rentetan ini.
Sekali lagi, bila kita bekerja dengan model query, kita tak risau tentang cara melaksanakan gate query ini.
Itu adalah isu yang sama yang kita ada dengan gate query untuk circuit Boolean.
Bukan kerja kita untuk menyediakan input, kita diberikan input dalam bentuk gate query ini.
Walau bagaimanapun, nak tunjuk bahawa kalau kita tahu cara melaksanakan fungsi f menggunakan circuit Boolean, maka adalah mungkin untuk menterjemahkan pelaksanaan tu
terus ke pelaksanaan circuit kuantum Uf, dan kita akan tengok betul-betul macam mana benda tu berfungsi dalam pelajaran seterusnya.
Sebagai tambahan, ia cukup mudah untuk mencipta circuit Boolean yang beroperasi seperti ini, menggunakan satu gate query klasik untuk fungsi f,
tapi itu sangat berbeza daripada mempunyai pelaksanaan circuit kuantum bagi gate unitari ini.
Walau bagaimanapun, intinya ialah bahawa untuk algoritma query klasik, mempunyai gate query yang berfungsi seperti ini adalah, sebenarnya, setara
dengan mempunyai gate query klasik biasa untuk f, dalam erti kata sama ada satunya boleh dilaksanakan menggunakan yang lain.
Dalam bahagian pelajaran ini, kita akan bincang algoritma Deutsch, yang merupakan algoritma query kuantum yang sangat mudah, tapi ia memang permata.
Algoritma ini datang dari makalah 1985 yang ditulis oleh David Deutsch, yang merupakan salah seorang yang pertama bekerja pada asas teori pengiraan kuantum.
Algoritma itu sendiri mewakili bahagian yang sangat kecil daripada makalah 1985 Deutsch, dan sebenarnya,
algoritma yang kini kita panggil algoritma Deutsch sebenarnya adalah versi yang lebih baik daripada algoritma yang Deutsch huraikan.
Ia memberikan contoh yang sangat sederhana tentang bagaimana komputer kuantum boleh menawarkan kelebihan pengiraan, tapi kita kena mulakan dari suatu tempat,
dan ia memang adalah percikan penting yang memulakan segalanya.
Algoritma Deutsch menyelesaikan masalah query yang sering dipanggil masalah Deutsch dalam konteks pengiraan kuantum,
tapi sebenarnya, ia bukan lain daripada masalah pariti untuk fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit, yang dah kita bincang.
Seperti yang dah kita nampak, ada empat fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit, dan ia diterangkan di sini pada skrin dengan jadual nilai-nilainya.
Fungsi pertama dan terakhir adalah malar, manakala dua yang tengah adalah seimbang dalam erti kata kedua-dua nilai output yang mungkin
muncul dengan bilangan yang sama.
Untuk dua fungsi malar, kita nampak bahawa pariti, atau dengan kata lain, XOR eksklusif kedua-dua output adalah 0,
dan untuk dua fungsi seimbang, pariti output adalah 1.
Jadi cara setara untuk menerangkan masalah pariti dalam kes khusus ini, di mana fungsi f mengambil satu bit sebagai input,
atau dengan kata lain, masalah Deutsch, adalah seperti yang kita tengok di sini.
Input adalah fungsi f dari satu bit ke satu bit, dan outputnya adalah 0 jika f adalah malar
dan 1 jika f adalah seimbang.
Seperti yang dah saya cadangkan, setiap algoritma query klasik yang menyelesaikan masalah ini mesti membuat sekurang-kurangnya dua query kepada f.
Kalau kita hanya belajar satu daripada dua nilai output f, kita masih langsung tak ada maklumat tentang pariti dua output tu.
Dan ini, by the way, adalah benar walaupun untuk algoritma klasik yang menggunakan rawak.
Rawak kadang-kadang sangat berguna untuk menyelesaikan masalah query, dan kita akan tengok contoh sikit lagi dalam pelajaran ini,
tapi rawak tak membantu di sini.
Jadi algoritma kita dari tadi adalah optimum di kalangan algoritma query klasik untuk masalah Deutsch.
Sekarang kita akan tengok algoritma Deutsch, yang merupakan algoritma query kuantum yang menyelesaikan masalah Deutsch menggunakan satu query sahaja.
Dan ini adalah algoritma yang diterangkan sebagai circuit kuantum.
Kita ada dua qubit yang dimulakan seperti yang kita tengok di sini, dengan yang atas dimulakan kepada cat 0 dan yang bawah dimulakan kepada cat 1,
dan kita akan tengok mengapa kita mulakan qubit-qubit ini seperti ini sebentar lagi.
Kita lakukan gate Hadamard pada dua qubit, masukkan ia ke dalam gate query, lakukan gate Hadamard lain pada qubit teratas,
dan kemudian ukur. Dan tuntutannya ialah hasil pengukuran memberi kita, dengan kepastian, jawapan yang betul kepada masalah.
Jadi jom kita analisis circuit satu langkah pada satu masa untuk tengok dengan tepat bagaimana ia berfungsi.
Keadaan dua qubit selepas lapisan pertama gate Hadamard adalah hasil darab tensor keadaan minus dan plus.
Hadamard di atas memetakan keadaan 0 kepada keadaan plus, dan Hadamard di bawah memetakan keadaan 1 kepada keadaan minus.
Qubit atas ada di sebelah kanan, dan qubit bawah ada di sebelah kiri, jadi ini adalah keadaan yang kita dapat.
Adalah sangat penting bahawa qubit bawah berada dalam keadaan minus, by the way, ini tak akan berfungsi kalau kita mulakan qubit bawah
kepada keadaan 0 dan bukannya keadaan 1.
Kita nak kembangkan keadaan ini separuh jalan, seperti yang kita tengok di sini.
Sebab untuk buat tu tak jelas pada ketika ini, tapi ia akan berguna sebentar lagi.
Seterusnya, jom fikir tentang keadaan dua qubit selepas gate query dilakukan.
Cara gate query berfungsi ialah ia mengira F pada keadaan asas standard qubit teratas dan meng-XOR nilai itu pada qubit bawah,
WEBVTT
dan di sini kita boleh tengok hasil melakukan tu.
Untuk sebutan pertama, keadaan asas standard qubit teratas adalah 0, jadi f of zero di-XOR-kan pada qubit bawah,
dan itu berfungsi dengan kelinearan. Dan sama untuk sebutan kedua, kecuali bahawa keadaan asas standard
untuk qubit teratas adalah 1, jadi kita XOR f of 1 pada qubit bawah.
Dan pada ketika ini, kita boleh ringkaskan ungkapan ini dengan memerhati formula yang kita boleh lihat di sini, yang berfungsi bila a adalah sama ada 0 atau 1.
Dan kita boleh semak sahaja ini untuk kedua-dua nilai itu secara berasingan.
Kalau a bersamaan dengan 0, maka meng-XOR dengan a tak buat apa-apa, dan negatif 1 pangkat 0 adalah 1,
jadi kedua-dua belah adalah sama. Dan kalau a bersamaan dengan 1, kita dapat cat 1 tolak cat 0 bila kita ambil XOR,
yang adalah negatif 1 darab cat 0 tolak cat 1.
Dan kalau kita guna formula tu untuk ringkaskan keadaan kita, di mana kita ambil a bersamaan dengan f of 0 di sebelah kiri dan a bersamaan dengan f of 1 di sebelah kanan,
kita dapat ungkapan yang kita tengok di sini.
Jadi bila kita bandingkan dua vektor keadaan kuantum π1 dan π2, kita nampak bahawa apa yang gate Uf buat
adalah berkesan meletakkan salah satu daripada dua nilai, f of 0 atau f of 1, ke dalam eksponen negatif 1,
atau dengan kata lain, ke dalam fasa setiap sebutan.
Ini adalah sebab untuk memulakan qubit bawah kepada 1 dan melakukan gate Hadamard padanya untuk mencipta keadaan minus, yang membolehkan perkara ini berlaku.
Ia dipanggil fenomena kickback fasa, dan kita akan kembali kepadanya dalam beberapa saat untuk melihatnya dari sudut yang berbeza.
Ia cukup penting, dan kita akan nampak ia berlaku beberapa kali lagi dalam pelajaran ini, serta dalam pelajaran-pelajaran kemudian.
Kita kini boleh ringkaskan dengan menarik balik keadaan minus ke luar untuk mendapat ungkapan yang kita tengok di sini.
Sebagai tambahan, agak menarik untuk perasan bahawa sebenarnya tak ada jalinan di sini.
Kedua-dua keadaan ini adalah keadaan produk. Jadi, walaupun jalinan sangat menarik,
ia tidak memainkan sebarang peranan langsung dalam algoritma tertentu ini.
Jom kita kemas sikit supaya kita ada lebih banyak ruang.
Apa yang kita boleh buat sekarang adalah menarik faktor negatif 1 pangkat f of zero ke luar
untuk mendapat ungkapan keadaan yang kita tengok di sini.
Kita akan nampak bahawa di sini, kita ada XOR eksklusif f 0 dan f 1 dalam eksponen negatif 1.
Kita mungkin jangkakan bahawa itu adalah f of 1 tolak f of 0 sebab kita tarik keluar faktor negatif 1 pangkat f of 0,
tapi kita dapat nilai yang sama kalau kita ambil XOR sebab ini adalah bit, dan satu-satunya perkara yang penting bila kita ada integer dalam eksponen negatif 1
ialah sama ada integer tu genap atau ganjil.
Cara lain untuk nyatakan keadaan ini adalah seperti yang kita ada di sini, di mana kita hanya mempertimbangkan dua kes yang mungkin untuk XOR.
dan itu adalah cara yang mudah untuk nyatakan keadaan bila kita pertimbangkan tindakan gate Hadamard terakhir bersama dengan pengukuran.
Bila kita lakukan gate Hadamard terakhir pada qubit teratas, keadaan plus diubah menjadi keadaan 0
dan keadaan minus diubah menjadi keadaan 1, yang boleh kita tulis dengan lebih ringkas seperti ini.
Dan akhirnya, bila pengukuran dilakukan, hasil yang kita peroleh adalah XOR f 0 dan f 1,
yang merupakan nilai yang kita cari, dan itulah cara algoritma Deutsch berfungsi.
Ia cukup mudah, dan kalau kita tanya diri kita apa yang membuatnya berfungsi, membolehkan kita mengira pariti dua bit
dengan satu query dan bukannya dua, jawapan yang munasabah adalah interferens.
Kita berkesan mengira f of 0 dan f of 1 pada masa yang sama, sebab kita mula-mula lakukan gate Hadamard
pada qubit teratas untuk meletakkan input kepada f dalam superposisi 0 dan 1.
Dan melalui kickback fasa bersama dengan gate Hadamard terakhir, kita pada dasarnya mencipta interferens membina
untuk jawapan yang betul dan interferens memusnah untuk jawapan yang salah.
Jadi kita tak nampak jawapan yang salah, kita hanya nampak jawapan yang betul.
Biarkan saya cakap sikit lagi tentang fenomena kickback fasa untuk melihatnya dari sudut yang sedikit berbeza.
Pertama, jom perhatikan formula yang sangat mudah ini di mana b dan c adalah nilai binari yang sewenang-wenangnya.
Ringkasnya, meng-XOR bit b dengan nilai 1 adalah sama dengan melakukan gate NOT atau operasi x pada b,
dan sudah tentu, meng-XOR bit b dengan nilai 0 tak buat apa-apa padanya, yang sama dengan melakukan operasi identiti padanya.
Dan kita boleh nyatakan operasi identiti sebagai x pangkat 0.
Jadi kalau kita lakukan gate Uf pada dua qubit dalam keadaan asas standard cat b tensor cat a,
kita dapat hasil ini, hanya berdasarkan definisi gate Uf.
WEBVTT
dan dengan menggunakan formula tu, kita boleh tulis keadaan itu secara alternatif seperti yang kita tengok di sini.
Formula ini berfungsi untuk semua pilihan b, jadi dengan kelinearan, ia berfungsi untuk keadaan SI yang sewenang-wenangnya
sebagai ganti cat b.
Dan khususnya, kalau kita nak, kita boleh pilih SI sebagai keadaan minus.
Dan inilah kuncinya kenapa fenomena kickback fasa x berlaku.
Ia kerana operasi x yang dikenakan pada keadaan minus memberi kita negatif 1 darab keadaan minus.
Dari segi matematik, kita cakap bahawa keadaan minus adalah eigenvector operasi x, dengan eigen value bersamaan dengan negatif 1.
Eigenvector dan eigen value adalah sangat penting dalam aljabar linear mahupun dalam maklumat kuantum, dan kita akan ada banyak lagi benda nak cakap tentang ia
bila siri ini diteruskan.
Tapi buat masa ni, semua yang kita perlukan adalah formula mudah ini.
Dan menggunakannya, kita boleh ringkaskan vektor keadaan kita.
Dan itulah pada dasarnya fenomena kickback fasa yang ditulis sebagai formula.
Ia berfungsi sebab keadaan minus adalah eigenvector operasi NOT yang mempunyai eigen value negatif satu.
Kita akan generalisasikan ini dengan cara yang cukup besar dalam Pelajaran 7, bila kita beralih kepada prosedur anggaran fasa, yang merupakan apa yang mendorong algoritma pemfaktoran Shor.
Kita boleh tengok formula ini beraksi dalam analisis algoritma Deutsch seperti berikut.
Sebelum gate query, keadaan kita adalah hasil darab tensor keadaan minus dan plus.
Kita kemudian kenakan gate query, dan mengembangkan keadaan plus memberi kita keadaan ini.
Kita kini kenakan formula kickback fasa untuk mendapat ungkapan ini, dan kemudian analisis diteruskan seperti sebelumnya.
Ia sama seperti sebelumnya, tapi di sini kita hanya meletakkan fokus pada kickback fasa supaya kita boleh mengenalinya
dan kita juga boleh bersedia untuknya bila ia muncul semula.
Seterusnya kita akan beralih kepada algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, yang merupakan sambungan algoritma Deutsch yang sebenarnya menyelesaikan beberapa masalah query yang berbeza.
Kelebihan yang diberikan algoritma Deutsch berbanding algoritma klasik agak sederhana, satu query berbanding dua.
Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa meningkatkan kelebihan tu agak lebih, dan saya akan jelaskan apa yang saya maksudkan bila kita sampai ke sana.
Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa boleh dilihat sebagai cara natural dan langsung untuk memperluaskan algoritma Deutsch
dari fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit kepada fungsi dari n bit ke satu bit, atau dengan kata lain, fungsi berbentuk ini.
Sebagai circuit kuantum, algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa kelihatan seperti ini, dan saya akan rujuk ini sebagai circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
hanya untuk membuat sedikit perbezaan antara circuit ini dan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa itu sendiri sebab ada juga langkah pasca-pemprosesan klasik.
Ideanya ialah kalau kita jalankan circuit ini dan kemudian ukur, kita akan mendapat beberapa rentetan n bit y
yang memberitahu kita sesuatu tentang fungsi f.
Pada ketika ini, by the way, saya sebenarnya belum cakap apa masalah query yang kita mungkin harap untuk diselesaikan dengan circuit ini, itu akan datang sangat segera.
Tapi intinya ialah bahawa dengan menjalankan circuit ini, kita akan mendapat beberapa maklumat tentang f yang berpotensi membantu kita menyelesaikan masalah query
di mana f adalah input. Dan seperti yang saya cakap sebentar tadi, kita sebenarnya boleh guna circuit ini
untuk menyelesaikan beberapa masalah query yang berbeza.
Pertama, jom tengok masalah query yang dikenali sebagai masalah Deutsch-Jozsa, yang merupakan masalah yang circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
pada asalnya bertujuan untuk diselesaikan.
Masalah Deutsch-Jozsa adalah generalisasi masalah Deutsch, di mana matlamatnya adalah untuk menentukan sama ada fungsi yang diberikan adalah malar atau seimbang.
Perhatikan bahawa ini bukan cara natural untuk menggeneralisasikan masalah pariti kepada fungsi berbentuk ini.
Di sini kita tak mengira pariti, tugasnya adalah untuk output 0 kalau fungsi f adalah malar
dan 1 kalau fungsi f adalah seimbang.
Perkara pertama yang perlu diperhatikan tentang masalah ini ialah bila n, bilangan bit input kepada fungsi f, adalah sekurang-kurangnya 2,
ada pilihan untuk fungsi yang bukan malar mahupun seimbang.
Contohnya, ini adalah fungsi dari 2 bit ke 1 bit yang bukan malar mahupun seimbang.
Ia bukan malar sebab kedua-dua nilai binari muncul dalam output, dan ia bukan seimbang sebab dua nilai output
muncul dengan kekerapan yang berbeza. 0 muncul tiga kali dan 1 muncul hanya sekali.
Agar seimbang, output 0 dan 1 mesti berlaku dengan tepat bilangan yang sama.
Fakta bahawa ada fungsi yang bukan malar mahupun seimbang bila n adalah sekurang-kurangnya 2 adalah okay, kita hanya akan pertimbangkan fungsi-fungsi seperti tu
sebagai input "tak kisah". Jadi dengan kata lain, ini adalah masalah janji.
Dan ini adalah pernyataan tepat masalah itu.
WEBVTT
Kita dijanjikan bahawa fungsi input f adalah sama ada malar atau seimbang, dan matlamatnya adalah untuk mengetahui mana satunya.
Dan kita tak bertanggungjawab untuk apa yang berlaku kalau input tak memenuhi janji.
Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, yang menyelesaikan masalah ini, adalah pertama menjalankan circuit Deutsch-Jozsa dan kemudian output 0
kalau rentetan yang kita dapat dari pengukuran adalah rentetan semua-sifar dan output 1 kalau tidak.
Cara lain untuk cakap benda tu ialah kita output OR bit-bit yang kita ukur.
Untuk menganalisis algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, akan berguna untuk ambil beberapa saat dulu untuk fikir tentang gate Hadamard.
Kita boleh, sudah tentu, huraikan operasi Hadamard sebagai matriks, tapi kita juga boleh huraikannya dari segi tindakannya
pada keadaan asas standard, seperti yang kita tengok di sini.
Dua persamaan ini boleh digabungkan menjadi satu persamaan, yang menerangkan bagaimana operasi Hadamard berfungsi untuk a yang mana-mana daripada dua nilai binari,
dan kita boleh pergi sikit lebih jauh dan nyatakan apa yang kita dapat sebagai jumlah seperti ini.
Menggunakan formula tu, kita boleh membuat formula yang menerangkan bagaimana lapisan gate Hadamard berfungsi, di mana kita kenakan satu gate Hadamard pada setiap n qubit.
Di sini kita menerangkan tindakan ini pada keadaan asas standard.
Dan untuk jelaskan notasinya, bila kita tulis h tensor n seperti ini, di mana bahagian tensor n adalah superskrip,
yang kita maksudkan adalah hasil darab tensor n kali H dengan dirinya sendiri, atau dengan kata lain, n salinan h yang semuanya di-tensor bersama.
Kita mengenakan operasi ini pada keadaan asas standard, dan di sini saya mengikut konvensyen yang Qiskit gunakan
untuk mengindeks rentetan binari, hanya sebab ini masa yang baik untuk memperkenalkan konvensyen tu.
Jadi x0 adalah bit, x1 adalah bit, dan seterusnya dengan n bit secara keseluruhan, dan bit-bit disusun seperti yang kita tengok di skrin.
Kita boleh fikir tentang cara pengindeksan bit ini sebagai sepadan dengan kepentingannya kalau kita lihat rentetan sebagai mewakili integer
dalam notasi binari, contohnya.
Kalau kita kenakan gate Hadamard pada setiap qubit ini, kita boleh nyatakan hasilnya secara alternatif sebagai hasil darab tensor n kali
gate Hadamard yang dikenakan pada setiap qubit, dan kemudian kita boleh kenakan formula kita pada setiap satu daripada faktor tensor.
Dan di sini kita guna nama y dan negatif 1 turun kepada y1 sebagai ganti b dalam formula,
jadi ini adalah nilai binari. Dan kita pastikan guna nama baru setiap kali kita guna formula tu.
Kalau kita kemudian kembangkan segalanya menggunakan multikelinearan hasil darab tensor, kita dapat ungkapan yang kita tengok di sini.
Dan jelasnya, n jumlah digabungkan menjadi satu jumlah, tapi kita masih menjumlahkan semua nilai yang mungkin
untuk nilai-nilai binari individu.
Sekarang jom kita kemas benda-benda supaya kita boleh pergi sikit lebih jauh.
Dan langkah seterusnya adalah untuk memperkenalkan operasi baru pada rentetan yang dipanggil hasil titik binari.
Ini adalah operasi pada rentetan binari yang mempunyai panjang yang sama.
Dan hasil titik binari dua rentetan x dan y yang sama panjang adalah XOR eksklusif atau pariti
hasil darab bit-bit individu.
Kita juga boleh cakap bahawa ia adalah XOR AND logik bit-bit individu, sebab AND adalah sama dengan hasil darab
untuk nilai binari. Cara lain lagi untuk menerangkannya ialah ia adalah 1 atau 0
bergantung pada sama ada jumlah hasil darab bit-bit individu adalah ganjil atau genap.
Ia sangat mirip hasil darab dalam jika kita fikir tentang rentetan sebagai vektor nilai binari, tapi di mana kita kira Modulo-2,
atau dengan kata lain, kita ambil baki selepas dibahagi dengan 2.
Ia sebenarnya bukan hasil darab dalam, jadi ia perlu nama yang berbeza.
Dalam kes ini, kita boleh guna hasil titik binari untuk jadikan formula kita untuk tindakan lapisan gate Hadamard
pada keadaan asas standard lebih ringkas, dan ini dia.
Kita guna fakta bahawa sebab jumlah ini muncul dalam eksponen negatif 1,
satu-satunya perkara yang penting adalah sama ada ia genap atau ganjil, tapi selain tu, ia pada dasarnya hanya versi yang lebih padat daripada formula kita.
By the way, hasil titik binari adalah simetri dalam erti kata bahawa x titik y dan y titik x adalah sama,
jadi kita bebas untuk menukar susunannya bila itu berguna.
Dan sekarang kita ada formula tu, ia akan cukup mudah untuk menganalisis circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
Kita mulakan dengan n qubit dalam keadaan 0 dan qubit bawah dalam keadaan 1, dan kita lakukan gate Hadamard pada semuanya.
Jadi ini adalah keadaan n + 1 qubit yang kita dapat.
Kita merawat qubit bawah secara berasingan sebab itu akan memudahkan.
Dan sekali lagi, kita akan nampak fenomena kickback fasa berlaku.
WEBVTT
Kita boleh dapat ungkapan ini dengan menggunakan formula kita, di mana kita gantikan rentetan semua-sifar untuk x dan gantikan x untuk y,
dengan menyedari bahawa hasil titik binari rentetan semua-sifar dengan mana-mana rentetan adalah 0.
Tapi kita juga boleh fikir ini secara terus. Kita mengambil hasil darab tensor n keadaan plus, dan ini yang kita dapat,
di-tensor kepada keadaan minus. Kemudian gate UF dikenakan, dan inilah tempat fenomena kickback fasa berlaku.
Nilai f of x di-XOR-kan pada keadaan minus untuk setiap x dalam jumlah.
Jadi f of x dikick ke dalam fasa.
Kita kini kenakan lapisan lain gate Hadamard hanya pada n qubit teratas, dan kali ini, kita memang perlukan formula tu.
Dan bila kita kenakan ia dan buat sedikit ringkasan, kita dapat keadaan ini di sini.
Jadi itulah keadaan akhir kita sebelum pengukuran.
Keadaan tu nampak agak rumit, dan susah nak ringkaskannya sebab kita sebenarnya tak tahu apa-apa tentang fungsi f.
Tapi ingat, semua yang kita perlu tahu ialah sama ada pengukuran semua menghasilkan hasil 0 atau tidak,
sebab itulah yang menentukan jawapan kita kepada masalah.
Kalau kita nampak bahawa setiap hasil pengukuran adalah 0, kita simpulkan bahawa fungsi itu adalah malar.
Dan kalau mana-mana satu hasil pengukuran adalah 1, kita simpulkan bahawa fungsi itu adalah seimbang.
Jadi jom kita kira kebarangkalian untuk mendapat rentetan semua-sifar dari pengukuran.
Dan itu rupanya adalah satu-satunya keputusan yang sebenarnya mudah untuk dikira, sebab hasil titik binari rentetan semua-sifar
dengan mana-mana rentetan adalah sifar. Kalau kita periksa vektor kita dan kita fikir tentang apa yang berlaku bila y adalah rentetan semua-sifar,
kita dapat ungkapan ini untuk kebarangkalian mendapat rentetan semua-sifar dari pengukuran.
Dan mempertimbangkan dua kes yang mungkin di mana f adalah malar dan f adalah seimbang, kita nampak bahawa kebarangkalian untuk mendapat rentetan semua-sifar adalah 1
dalam kes f adalah malar, dan sifar bila f adalah seimbang.
Bila f adalah malar, jumlahnya adalah sama ada 2 pangkat n atau negatif 2 pangkat n, dan dibahagi dengan dua pangkat n
dan mengambil nilai mutlak kuasa dua menghasilkan 1.
Dan bila f adalah seimbang, jumlahnya bersamaan dengan 0.
Itu sebab kita akan dapat positif 1 dan negatif 1 dengan bilangan yang sama, jadi ia semua saling menghapuskan.
Itulah dia. Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa menyelesaikan masalah Deutsch-Jozsa menggunakan satu query sahaja,
dan tiada ralat. Dengan mengandaikan semua operasi dilakukan dengan sempurna, ia betul setiap kali.
Jadi macam mana ia dibandingkan dengan apa yang boleh kita buat secara klasik?
Nah, kalau kita desak pada algoritma deterministik yang mendapat jawapan betul setiap kali, maka dalam kes terburuk,
kita perlu 2 pangkat n tolak 1 tambah 1 query, dan itu sebab kita kena query fungsi tu
pada lebih daripada separuh inputnya untuk pastikan penyelesaian.
Walaupun kita query fungsi pada 2 pangkat n tolak 1 rentetan input berbeza, adalah mungkin kita akan nampak nilai output yang sama
setiap kali, dan itu mungkin sebab fungsi itu adalah malar, atau mungkin ia sebenarnya seimbang
dan kita sangat bernasib malang telah nampak nilai output yang sama setiap kali.
Jadi itu adalah kelebihan yang besar bagi kuantum berbanding klasik, satu query berbanding banyak query secara eksponen.
Walau bagaimanapun, kalau kita guna algoritma query probabilistik dan kita terima kebarangkalian kecil bahawa ia menjawab dengan salah,
maka kita sebenarnya hanya perlukan beberapa query sahaja.
Khususnya, kalau kita pilih k rentetan secara rawak dan nilai fungsi pada rentetan-rentetan rawak tu,
maka kita cukup berkemungkinan untuk dapat cari jawapan yang betul.
Khususnya, kita jawab 0 atau malar bila kita dapat nilai fungsi yang sama setiap kali dan 1 atau seimbang
bila kita nampak dua nilai fungsi yang berbeza.
Kalau kita buat tu, kita akan sentiasa betul bila fungsi adalah malar sebab, sudah tentu, kita akan sentiasa nampak nilai output yang sama dalam kes ini.
Dan kalau f adalah seimbang, kita sangat berkemungkinan untuk nampak dua nilai output yang berbeza.
Peluang bahawa kita tak nampak kedua-dua nilai output dalam kes ini adalah sama dengan peluang kita untuk membalik syiling k kali
dan mendapat hasil yang sama setiap kali.
Jadi contohnya, kalau kita set k bersamaan dengan 11, kebarangkalian mendapat jawapan yang salah adalah kurang daripada sepersepuluh persen.
Jadi terutamanya bila kita pertimbangkan fakta bahawa komputer kuantum tak akan pernah sempurna dalam kenyataan, kita sebenarnya tak dapat kelebihan yang begitu besar di sini,
tapi kita sedang membuat kemajuan, dan kita memang ada kelebihan kuantum berbanding klasik yang boleh dikuantifikasi yang melangkaui algoritma Deutsch.
Kita juga boleh guna circuit Deutsch-Jozsa untuk menyelesaikan masalah query yang berbeza yang dikenali sebagai masalah Bernstein-Vazirani.
Ini adalah pernyataan masalah tu. Input adalah fungsi dari n bit ke 1 bit, sama seperti masalah Deutsch-Jozsa,
WEBVTT
dan sekali lagi, ia adalah masalah janji.
Kali ini, janjinya ialah ada rentetan n bit s yang mana fungsi f berfungsi seperti yang kita tengok di sini,
di mana outputnya diberikan oleh hasil titik binari input dengan rentetan s ini,
dan matlamatnya adalah mudah sahaja iaitu untuk mencari rentetan s. Jadi kita boleh bayangkan bahawa rentetan s tersembunyi dalam erti kata tertentu,
tapi kita boleh belajar tentangnya dengan membuat query kepada f, dan matlamat kita adalah untuk mencari rentetan tersembunyi ini.
Jelasnya, kebanyakan fungsi tak akan memenuhi janji ini, tapi seperti biasa, kita hanya ambil kisah tentang fungsi input yang memenuhinya.
Rupanya, circuit Deutsch-Jozsa sebenarnya menyelesaikan masalah ini terus sahaja.
Kalau kita jalankan ia untuk fungsi seperti yang kita ada di sini yang memenuhi janji untuk beberapa rentetan s, pengukuran akan mendedahkan rentetan s
tanpa pemprosesan selepasnya yang diperlukan.
Jadi jom tengok macam mana ini berfungsi.
Kita dah analisis circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, jadi kita sebenarnya boleh terus ke bahagian akhir sahaja.
Ini adalah ungkapan yang kita ada sebelum ini untuk keadaan sebelum pengukuran, dan ungkapan itu sah untuk mana-mana fungsi f.
Dan sekarang, kalau kita gantikan apa yang dijanjikan tentang fungsi f dan ringkaskan,
kita dapat keadaan minus untuk qubit bawah di-tensor dengan cat s untuk n qubit teratas.
Dan jadi kita dapat s bila kita ukur.
Ada beberapa kerja yang perlu dilakukan untuk melakukan ringkasan yang saya tunjukkan di sini, dan saya tak akan melaluinya dalam video ini,
tapi ada lebih banyak perincian tentangnya dalam kandungan buku teks untuk siri ini, yang boleh kita jumpa dengan mengikut pautan dalam penerangan video,
atau cuba sendiri untuk berlatih.
Jadi apa yang kita dapati ialah circuit Deutsch-Jozsa menyelesaikan masalah Bernstein-Vazirani dengan satu query sahaja.
Tak terlalu susah untuk tunjukkan bahawa mana-mana algoritma klasik, sama ada deterministik atau probabilistik, perlukan sekurang-kurangnya n query
untuk menyelesaikan masalah Bernstein-Vazirani atas sebab mudah bahawa kita perlukan n bit maklumat untuk dapatkan semula s,
dan setiap query memberi kita paling banyak 1 bit maklumat.
Jadi kita dapat kelebihan lain kuantum berbanding algoritma query klasik, satu query untuk algoritma kuantum,
n query untuk algoritma klasik.
Berbaloi untuk ambil masa sekejap untuk bercakap tentang peristilahan yang digunakan dalam konteks masalah ini dan sikit tentang sejarahnya.
Orang kadang-kadang merujuk kepada algoritma yang baru saya huraikan sebagai algoritma Bernstein-Vazirani, tapi ia sebenarnya hanya circuit Deutsch-Jozsa,
dan itu adalah sesuatu yang, sebenarnya, dinyatakan dengan jelas dalam kerja Bernstein dan Vazirani.
Jadi agak pelik bahawa ia dipanggil algoritma Bernstein-Vazirani sebab ia pada dasarnya benda yang sama dengan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa
tolak pemprosesan selepasnya. Bernstein dan Vazirani memang, bagaimanapun, pergi selangkah lebih jauh.
Mereka takrifkan versi rekursif masalah ini, di mana kita pada dasarnya kena selesaikan contoh-contoh masalah Bernstein-Vazirani
untuk membuka contoh-contoh baru masalah yang disusun dalam corak seperti pokok yang rumit.
Ia adalah masalah yang sangat direka-reka, tapi intinya ialah dengan mentakrifkan masalah dengan cara ini, mereka boleh meregangkan secara berkesan
pemisahan query satu lawan n antara kuantum dan klasik.
Dan apa yang mereka peroleh adalah contoh pertama yang diketahui tentang kelebihan polinom super yang dipanggil kuantum berbanding algoritma probabilistik.
Versi rekursif masalah Bernstein-Vazirani ini juga rupanya menjadi sangat menarik kemudian dalam teori kerumitan pengiraan atas sebab yang berbeza.
Pokoknya, intinya ialah Bernstein dan Vazirani memang patut mendapat pengiktirafan atas sumbangan penting mereka,
tapi ia memang tak masuk akal untuk merujuk ini sebagai algoritma Bernstein-Vazirani, ia pada dasarnya hanya algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa.
Dalam bahagian terakhir pelajaran ini, kita akan tengok satu lagi algoritma query kuantum yang dikenali sebagai algoritma Simon.
Kita akan nampak persamaan yang jelas antara algoritma ini dan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, tapi ia berbeza, dan lebih penting lagi,
ia mendedahkan kelebihan yang jauh lebih kuat kuantum berbanding algoritma query klasik.
Khususnya, ia memberi kita kelebihan eksponen yang boleh dibuktikan kuantum berbanding algoritma klasik, walaupun yang probabilistik.
Masalah yang ia selesaikan agak buatan, dan susah nak bayangkan situasi di mana menyelesaikan masalah ini akan berguna,
tapi ia memang secara langsung menginspirasi penemuan Peter Shor tentang algoritma kuantum untuk pemfaktoran integer,
dan itu sangat kuat menyokong idea model query sebagai piring Petri di mana idea algoritma kuantum boleh dikembangkan.
Jom mulakan dengan masalah query yang diselesaikan oleh algoritma Simon, yang, seperti yang mungkin kita dah agak, dipanggil masalah Simon.
Ini adalah pernyataan masalah, dan kita perlu uraikannya untuk faham apa ia sebenarnya.
Perkara pertama yang perlu diperhatikan ialah kali ini, fungsi input f memetakan rentetan n bit kepada rentetan m bit
di mana m adalah integer positif yang tidak semestinya bersamaan dengan satu.
WEBVTT
Ia adalah masalah janji. Dan seperti masalah Bernstein-Vazirani, janji melibatkan beberapa rentetan s yang boleh kita lihat sebagai rentetan tersembunyi,
dan juga seperti masalah Bernstein-Vazirani, matlamatnya adalah untuk output rentetan tersembunyi s ini.
Janjinya lebih rumit kali ini, jadi jom kita uraikan dan faham apa yang dikatakannya.
Untuk mulakan, jom baca sahaja. Ia kata bahawa ada rentetan s yang panjangnya bersamaan dengan n
sedemikian rupa bahawa syarat "jika" dan "hanya jika" tertentu adalah benar untuk semua pilihan rentetan n bit x dan y.
Khususnya, ia mestilah benar bahawa f of x bersamaan dengan f of y jika dan hanya jika salah satu daripada dua kemungkinan berlaku.
Kemungkinan pertama ialah x bersamaan dengan y, dan kemungkinan kedua ialah dengan mengambil XOR eksklusif bitwise x
dengan rentetan tersembunyi s, kita dapat Y.
Ini rupanya adalah janji yang cukup ketat dalam erti kata kebanyakan fungsi tak akan memenuhinya.
Hanya fungsi yang sangat khas sahaja memenuhi syarat ini.
Sekarang, untuk faham janji ini dengan lebih baik dan oleh itu masalah itu sendiri, kita akan pertimbangkan dua kes utama.
Kes pertama ialah s adalah rentetan semua-sifar.
Dalam kes ini, kita boleh ringkaskan pernyataan "jika" dan "hanya jika" dalam janji sebab XOR eksklusif bitwise mana-mana rentetan x
dengan rentetan semua-sifar adalah mudah sahaja rentetan x itu.
Jadi syarat itu disederhanakan menjadi f of x bersamaan dengan f of y jika dan hanya jika x bersamaan dengan y.
Dan itu hanya cara lain untuk cakap bahawa f adalah fungsi satu ke satu.
Dengan kata lain, rentetan f of x mesti unik untuk setiap rentetan x yang mungkin.
Jadi kalau f adalah fungsi satu ke satu, maka janji memang dipenuhi, khususnya untuk s yang merupakan rentetan semua-sifar,
dan dalam kes ini, itulah output yang betul.
Kes kedua ialah s bukan rentetan semua-sifar, dan apa yang ini bermakna ialah fungsi f mestilah dua ke satu.
Jadi untuk setiap rentetan input x, ada tepat satu rentetan lain yang f petakan kepada rentetan yang sama dengan x dipetakan kepadanya,
dan lebih-lebih lagi, rentetan lain itu mestilah rentetan yang kita dapat dengan mengambil XOR eksklusif bitwise x dengan s.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya ialah setiap rentetan n bit x ada rakan, dan rakan itu adalah rentetan yang kita dapat
dengan mengambil XOR eksklusif bitwise dengan s.
Mana-mana dua rakan mesti memberi kita rentetan output yang sama kalau kita masukkan mereka ke dalam f, dan tiada rentetan lain dibenarkan untuk memberi kita rentetan output yang sama tu.
Jadi ini adalah rentetan yang berbeza semestinya yang dihasilkan oleh rakan-rakan.
Ini adalah contoh fungsi seperti ini yang diterangkan oleh jadual nilainya.
Jadi ini adalah fungsi dari 3 bit ke 5 bit.
Kalau kita renung jadual nilai ini sebentar, kita dapati bahawa janji dipenuhi untuk rentetan 011.
000 dan 011 adalah rakan. Meng-XOR mana-mana satunya dengan s memberi kita yang lain,
dan ia mengambil nilai output yang sama, iaitu 10011 dalam kes khusus ini, dan tiada rentetan lain yang menghasilkan rentetan output yang sama tu.
001 dan 010 adalah rakan sebab meng-XOR mana-mana satunya dengan s memberi yang lain, dan ia menghasilkan nilai output yang sama,
yang sekali lagi, tidak dihasilkan oleh rentetan lain.
Dan situasinya adalah sama untuk 100 dan 111 serta juga 101 dan 110.
Jadi kalau input kepada masalah adalah fungsi ini, jawapan yang betul adalah rentetan 011.
Seperti yang saya cakap sebelum ini, kebanyakan fungsi tak memenuhi janji ini, ia adalah syarat yang sangat khusus.
Perlu juga diperhatikan bahawa kalau janji dipenuhi, ia hanya boleh dipenuhi untuk satu rentetan s sahaja.
Jadi sentiasa ada satu sahaja jawapan yang betul untuk masalah ini.
Jadi itulah masalah Simon. Seperti yang saya cakap, susah nak bayangkan situasi praktikal di mana kita nak selesaikan masalah ini,
tapi itu bukan intinya. Intinya adalah untuk cuba cari apa yang komputer kuantum pandai buat, dan rupanya ia jauh lebih unggul
daripada algoritma klasik untuk menyelesaikan masalah tertentu ini.
Sekarang jom tengok algoritma Simon, yang menyelesaikan masalah Simon.
Algoritma ini terdiri daripada menjalankan circuit kuantum yang kita tengok di sini beberapa kali, diikuti oleh langkah pasca-pemprosesan klasik,
dan kita akan lebih spesifik tentang apa maksud beberapa kali sikit lagi.
Circuit tu kelihatan sangat serupa dengan circuit Deutsch-Jozsa, kali ini sebab fungsi f memetakan n bit kepada m bit,
gate query adalah berbeza. Bukannya hanya satu qubit di bawah, kita kini ada m qubit di bawah
dan n di atas seperti sebelumnya.
Perbezaan utama ialah kita tak menyediakan keadaan minus atau berbilang keadaan minus di bawah.
Qubit bawah ini semua dimulakan kepada keadaan 0, dan keadaan-keadaan tu terus masuk ke gate query.
WEBVTT
Jadi tak akan ada kickback fasa yang terlibat dalam algoritma ini, ia memang bukan cara algoritma ini berfungsi.
Selain perbezaan yang baru saya sebutkan tadi, ia nampak sangat serupa dengan circuit Deutsch-Jozsa.
Kita kenakan lapisan gate Hadamard, kemudian kita kenakan gate query sekali, dan kemudian kita kenakan lapisan lain gate Hadamard
diikuti dengan pengukuran asas standard n qubit teratas.
Ideanya ialah setiap kali kita jalankan circuit ini dan ukur, kita akan dapat beberapa rentetan y yang memberitahu kita sesuatu tentang rentetan tersembunyi s
dalam masalah Simon. Dan dengan menjalankan circuit beberapa kali secara bebas, kita akan mengumpulkan bukti statistik yang cukup tentang s
untuk dapat cari apa ia dengan keyakinan yang tinggi.
Sekarang jom analisis circuit kuantum untuk algoritma Simon untuk tengok apa yang ia buat.
Keadaan selepas lapisan pertama gate Hadamard kelihatan seperti ini, serupa dengan apa yang kita ada untuk algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa.
Kecuali kali ini, m qubit bawah semuanya dalam keadaan 0 bukannya dalam keadaan minus.
Selepas gate query dilakukan, kita nampak bahawa nilai f of x telah ditulis pada m qubit bawah atau paling kiri,
dan itu sebab f of x telah di-XOR-kan pada rentetan semua-sifar.
Jadi sekali lagi, tiada kickback fasa berlaku dalam algoritma ini.
Kita kemudian lakukan lapisan kedua gate Hadamard.
Dan menggunakan formula yang sama seperti sebelumnya untuk tindakan lapisan gate Hadamard pada keadaan asas standard, cat x dalam kes ini,
seperti dalam formula asal, kita dapat keadaan ini di sini, di mana tindakan gate Hadamard
telah dibuat lebih jelas. Tapi kalau kita nak, kita juga boleh tulis keadaan dalam bentuk yang lebih padat seperti yang kita ada di sini.
Pada ketika ini, kita ukur n qubit teratas untuk mendapat beberapa rentetan bit akhir y, dan kita hanya perlu cari apa kebarangkaliannya
untuk rentetan yang berbeza. Dan itu akan membantu kita memahami maklumat apa yang kita dapat dari rentetan y ini tentang rentetan s
yang tersembunyi di dalam fungsi f.
Kita perlu lebih banyak ruang untuk ini, dan kita sebenarnya tak perlukan rajah circuit lagi, jadi jom kita buang dan berikan diri kita lebih banyak ruang untuk analisis.
Ini adalah keadaan sebelum pengukuran, iaitu pengukuran asas standard n qubit teratas atau paling kanan.
Jadi pengukuran sepadan dengan cat kedua.
Jom nyatakan sebagai p of y, kebarangkalian bahawa pengukuran memberi kita rentetan y untuk setiap y yang mungkin.
Dan kalau kita ikut peraturan dari Pelajaran 2, kita dapat bahawa setiap kebarangkalian ini adalah norma Euclidean kuasa dua bagi vektor yang di-tensor kepada keadaan asas standard,
sepadan dengan kenapa dalam vektor keadaan kuantum kita.
Itu memberi kita ungkapan ini di sini.
Sekarang, untuk faham kebarangkalian-kebarangkalian ini dengan lebih baik, kita perlu guna beberapa notasi, dan mungkin kita dah biasa dengan notasi ini
sebab ia cukup biasa dalam matematik.
Pertama, bila kita merujuk kepada julat fungsi f, kita hanya bermaksud set semua rentetan yang boleh keluar dari fungsi ini.
Jadi ia adalah set semua f of x merentasi semua pilihan rentetan input x yang mungkin.
Kedua, kita akan guna notasi ini yang kita tengok di sini untuk bermaksud set semua rentetan input x
yang f petakan kepada rentetan z tertentu, untuk apa sahaja pilihan z yang kita nak pertimbangkan.
Ia nampak macam invers fungsi f, tapi ia sebenarnya bukan invers sebab f tidak semestinya boleh dibalikkan.
Kita juga nampak bahawa kita ada set sebagai argumen di sebelah kiri, dan dalam kes ini, ia adalah set yang mengandungi hanya satu rentetan z,
dan itulah petua yang kita perlukan untuk sedar bahawa kita tidak bercakap tentang invers fungsi f, ini dipanggil pra-imej.
Pra-imej boleh ditakrifkan dengan lebih umum untuk mana-mana set yang diberikan sebagai argumen, bukan hanya set yang mengandungi satu elemen,
tapi ini sahaja yang kita perlukan. Ia bukan notasi yang terbaik di dunia sebab mudah untuk mengelirukan ia dengan invers,
tapi ia cukup jelas dan digunakan secara meluas, jadi kita akan gunakannya.
Dan sekarang kalau kita guna notasi ini, kita boleh tulis semula vektor yang kita ambil norma Euclidean kuasa dua untuk mendapat kebarangkalian mengukur setiap rentetan y.
Kita buat ini sebab kita perlu tengok apa pekali bagi setiap keadaan asas standard individu, dan itu tak jelas dari ungkapan ini di sini,
sebab, secara umum, kita mungkin ada berbilang pilihan x yang memberi kita rentetan f of x yang sama.
Pada dasarnya, semua yang kita buat adalah memecahkan jumlah atas x dengan menjumlahkan dahulu semua z dalam julat f,
dan kemudian di dalam jumlah tu, menjumlahkan semua x dalam pra-imej z, atau untuk lebih tepat,
pra-imej set yang mengandungi rentetan z.
Itu membolehkan kita menggantikan f of x dengan z di dalam cat di sini.
Dan jumlah semua rentetan x berbeza yang f petakan kepada setiap z dikumpulkan ke dalam pekali bagi setiap cat.
Kita pada dasarnya meletakkan rentetan ke dalam bakul, menjumlahkan bakul-bakul, dan kemudian menjumlahkan rentetan dalam setiap bakul,
WEBVTT
tapi itu setara dengan hanya menjumlahkan semua rentetan.
Jadi kita memang mendapat ungkapan yang setara dengan yang kita mulakan,
dan sekarang kita boleh kira norma Euclidean kuasa dua.
Ia hanya jumlah kuasa dua nilai mutlak pekali, dan jadi, kita dapat ungkapan ini di sini
untuk kebarangkalian kita.
Sudah tentu, berikan diri kita masa untuk mengesahkan ini, kalau kita pilih nak buat tu, ia mengambil masa untuk biasa dengan semua ini
dan untuk dapat buat pengiraan-pengiraan ini, dan semakin banyak latihan yang kita berikan pada diri kita, semakin mudah ia akan jadi.
Setakat ini, kita sebenarnya tak guna janji dalam masalah Simon langsung.
Analisis kebarangkalian-kebarangkalian ini sebenarnya berfungsi untuk mana-mana fungsi f, tapi sekarang tiba masanya untuk fikir tentang masalah Simon secara khusus.
Kita akan pecahkan benda kepada dua kes yang sama seperti yang kita ada sebelum ini.
Kes pertama ialah s adalah rentetan semua-sifar, dan kes kedua ialah s bukan rentetan semua-sifar.
Dalam kes pertama, iaitu s adalah rentetan semua-sifar, benda agak mudah.
Dalam kes ini, seperti yang kita nampak sebelum ini, kita ada bahawa f adalah fungsi satu ke satu, jadi ada satu rentetan x
yang dipetakan kepada setiap rentetan z dalam julat f.
Itu menjadikan nilai mutlak kuasa dua jumlah atas rentetan-rentetan tu bersamaan dengan 1 sebab hanya ada satu sebutan dalam jumlah,
ia sama ada positif 1 atau negatif 1, tapi tak kisah mana sebab kita ambil nilai mutlak kuasa dua, dan jadi kita dapat satu.
Ada 2 pangkat n elemen dalam julat f, dan kita tahu bahawa sebab f adalah satu ke satu, jadi ada satu rentetan dalam julat untuk setiap rentetan input.
Dan kalau kita nilai keseluruhan ungkapan, kita dapati bahawa setiap rentetan y muncul dengan kebarangkalian satu per dua pangkat n.
Jadi dengan kata lain, pengukuran memberi kita rentetan y yang dipilih secara seragam rawak.
Itu mungkin tak nampak berguna sangat, tapi kita memang, sebenarnya, akan dapat membezakan tingkah laku ini dari tingkah laku yang kita dapat dalam kes
bahawa s bukan rentetan semua-sifar, dan kita akan tengok macam mana tu berlaku tidak lama lagi.
Buat masa ni, kita hanya perhatikan bahawa kalau f memenuhi janji dalam masalah Simon dalam kes bahawa s adalah rentetan semua-sifar,
maka hasil pengukuran adalah rentetan rawak seragam.
Sekarang jom beralih kepada kes kedua, iaitu janji dipenuhi untuk rentetan s yang bukan rentetan semua-sifar.
Dalam kes ini, seperti yang kita bincang sebelum ini, setiap rentetan z dalam julat f ada tepat dua rentetan yang dipetakan kepadanya,
sebab setiap rentetan ada rakan, dan setiap pasangan rakan dipetakan kepada rentetan unik, dan khususnya, rakan setiap rentetan
adalah rentetan yang kita dapat dengan meng-XOR dengan s.
Jadi kalau kita pilih mana-mana rentetan z dalam julat f, dan kita beri nama w kepada mana-mana satu rentetan yang f petakan kepada z,
maka XOR w dengan s adalah rentetan lain yang dipetakan kepada z.
Melihat hanya satu sebutan dalam jumlah kita yang sepadan dengan apa sahaja rentetan z dalam julat yang kita ada dalam fikiran,
kita nampak bahawa kita boleh tulis ia dengan lebih eksplisit seperti yang kita ada di sini.
Kita ada dua rentetan dalam pra-imej z, w dan w XOR dengan s.
Jadi kita boleh tulis jumlah seperti yang kita tengok di skrin, dan sekarang apa yang boleh kita buat adalah menarik keluar faktor negatif 1 pangkat w.y.
Faktor tu akan jadi sama ada positif 1 atau negatif 1, jadi ia hilang bila kita ambil nilai mutlak,
dan apa yang tinggal adalah ungkapan ini di sini.
Butiran tidak semua ditunjukkan di sini, dan tak semestinya jelas bahawa ia berfungsi begini, tapi kita boleh semak bahawa dua ungkapan ini adalah sama
dengan kembali kepada definisi hasil titik binari dan fikir tentang apa yang berlaku bila benda-benda ini berada dalam eksponen negatif 1,
tidak kurang seperti apa yang kita ada untuk masalah Bernstein-Vazirani.
Akhirnya, kita boleh pecahkan ungkapan ini kepada dua kes.
Ia adalah 4 bila hasil titik binari s dan y adalah 0, dan ia adalah 0 bila hasil titik binari s dan y adalah 1.
Perhatikan khususnya bahawa langsung tiada kebergantungan di sini pada w atau z, ia hanya bergantung pada s dan y.
Sebab ini berlaku adalah kerana sifat janji yang sangat khusus dan khas.
Pada dasarnya, inilah sebabnya janji diformulasikan dengan cara ini, supaya ia semua berjalan seperti ini.
Sekali lagi, setiap rentetan ada rakan, yang kita dapat dengan meng-XOR dengan rentetan tersembunyi s yang satu ini,
dan itulah yang menjadikan semua ini berlaku.
Kita kini boleh kembali kepada ungkapan kebarangkalian dan masukkan benda-benda tu.
Bila s bukan rentetan semua-sifar, ada 2 pangkat n tolak 1 elemen dalam julat f,
iaitu separuh bilangan rentetan input, dan memasukkan nilai yang baru kita kira memberi formula ini di sini.
Jadi kali ini, y bukan rentetan yang sepenuhnya rawak, sebaliknya y adalah seragam atas tepat separuh rentetan n bit,
WEBVTT
dan khususnya, ia adalah seragam atas rentetan-rentetan yang mempunyai hasil titik binari bersamaan dengan 0 dengan s.
Sekarang kita tahu macam mana circuit untuk algoritma Simon berfungsi dan khususnya apa kebarangkalian untuk hasil pengukuran yang berbeza,
tinggal lagi nak jelaskan macam mana ini membantu kita menyelesaikan masalah Simon.
Merumuskan apa yang baru kita pelajari, kalau memang benar bahawa fungsi f memenuhi janji dalam masalah Simon,
bila rentetan tersembunyi s adalah rentetan semua-sifar, kita mendapat rentetan yang sepenuhnya rawak dari pengukuran,
di mana setiap rentetan n bit y adalah sama kemungkinannya.
Kalau pula fungsi f memenuhi janji untuk rentetan s yang berbeza, yang tidak bersamaan dengan rentetan semua-sifar,
maka kita mendapat rentetan rawak y yang mempunyai hasil titik binari bersamaan dengan 0 dengan s, dan di antara semua rentetan tu, setiap y adalah sama kemungkinannya.
Tapi kita tak akan pernah mendapat rentetan y yang mempunyai hasil titik binari bersamaan dengan 1 dengan s.
Soalannya menjadi, "Adakah maklumat ini cukup untuk menentukan s?" Dan jawapannya, seperti yang dah saya cadangkan, adalah ya,
dengan syarat kita jalankan circuit cukup kali.
Khususnya, jom andaikan bahawa kita jalankan circuit k kali, di mana K bersamaan dengan n tambah r,
di mana r adalah beberapa nombor yang akan mengawal kemungkinan kita mendapatkan semula s.
Sebagai contoh sahaja, kalau kita pilih r bersamaan dengan 10, kita akan berjaya dengan kebarangkalian lebih daripada 99.9%,
jadi kita tak perlukan r yang terlalu besar.
Secara umum, kebarangkalian kegagalan adalah kurang daripada kebarangkalian membalik syiling adil r kali dan mendapat kepala setiap kali.
Jadi kalau 99.9% tak cukup baik, ambil r bersamaan dengan 20, dan peluang kegagalan adalah kurang daripada satu dalam sejuta,
atau pilih r yang mana sahaja yang selesa. Kita tak boleh jamin penyelesaian yang betul, tapi kita boleh jadikan kebarangkalian ralat boleh diabaikan
untuk semua tujuan praktik.
Di sini kita menamakan rentetan-rentetan ini y1 hingga yk, di mana kita guna superskrip untuk membantu kita menamakan rentetan-rentetan ini,
hanya supaya kita boleh simpan subskrip untuk merujuk kepada bit-bit individu rentetan-rentetan tu.
Jadi ini bukan eksponen atau apa-apa, ini hanya nama yang kita berikan kepada k rentetan ini.
Setiap satunya mempunyai panjang n sebab kita mendapatnya dari menjalankan circuit untuk algoritma Simon.
Jadi kita boleh tulis bit-bit individu k rentetan ini seperti yang kita tengok di sini.
Apa yang kita buat sekarang adalah mencipta matriks m, di mana setiap entri matriks ini adalah bit, dan kita dapat bit-bit ini dari rentetan
yang baru kita ukur, seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Jadi matriks ini mempunyai k baris dan n lajur, dan entri-entrinya adalah semua nilai binari.
Sekarang, kita tak tahu apa s. Itulah yang kita cuba cari, tapi bayangkan sebentar bahawa kita memang tahu s,
dan kita bentuk vektor lajur dari bit-bit s, seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Kalau kita darabkan vektor tu dengan m dan kemudian ambil hasilnya modulo-2, atau cara lain untuk mengatakannya
ialah kita gantikan penambahan dengan XOR eksklusif, maka kita semestinya akan dapat vektor semua-sifar.
Itu sebab setiap entri dalam vektor hasil ini bukan lain daripada hasil titik binari s
dengan satu baris m.
Kalau S kebetulan adalah rentetan semua-sifar, kita akan sentiasa dapat vektor sifar dari hasil titik binari.
Dan kalau s bukan rentetan semua-sifar, kita akan dapat ini dari apa yang kita tahu tentang kebarangkalian untuk rentetan y1 hingga yk muncul.
Khususnya, hasil titik binari dengan s sentiasa sifar untuk semua rentetan ini.
Cara mudah untuk mengatakan itu ialah vektor yang dibentuk dari bit-bit s sentiasa berada dalam ruang nul matriks m,
dengan mengandaikan bahawa kita melakukan semua aritmetik modulo-2, tapi sudah tentu, kita tak tahu apa s,
kita sedang mencuba mencari s.
Tapi apa yang boleh kita buat ialah kita boleh kira ruang nul matriks m ini, sekali lagi, modulo-2.
Khususnya, kita boleh buat itu menggunakan teknik penghapusan Gaussian, yang merupakan prosedur yang sering diajar
dalam kursus aljabar linear pengantar.
Ia berfungsi dengan baik bila kita melakukan semua aritmetik modulo-2, dan ia boleh dilakukan dengan cukup cekap menggunakan komputer.
Dan kalau kita kira ruang nul m, berdasarkan cara khusus k rentetan ini dipilih secara rawak,
kita akan dapat mendapatkan semula s dengan kebarangkalian lebih daripada 1 tolak 2 pangkat negatif r.
Untuk spesifik, apa yang akan kita nampak dengan kebarangkalian lebih daripada 1 tolak 2 pangkat negatif r ialah ruang nul merangkumi vektor semua-sifar,
seperti yang selalu berlaku untuk setiap matriks, serta vektor yang sepadan dengan s, sama ada ia adalah vektor semua-sifar atau tidak.
Dan yang paling penting, tiada vektor lain akan muncul dalam ruang nul.
Sebenarnya tak terlalu susah untuk buktikan ini, walaupun saya tak akan melaluinya secara terperinci.
WEBVTT
Ideanya ialah kalau kita ada beberapa rentetan lain yang bukan vektor semua-sifar dan bukan s, maka setiap satu rentetan rawak, y1 hingga yk,
pada dasarnya akan mengeluarkannya dari ruang nul dengan kebarangkalian separuh.
Jadi selepas k pukulan, ia tidak akan mungkin sama sekali untuk bertahan, dan sebenarnya, tiada satu pun rentetan yang tidak termasuk
yang mungkin untuk bertahan. Dan fakta yang sangat mudah dari teori kebarangkalian, yang dikenali sebagai batas kesatuan, boleh digunakan untuk membuktikan itu.
Saya tak jelaskan semua butiran di sini, tapi mudah-mudahan, kita faham idea bahawa dengan mengira ruang nul modulo-2 matriks m ini,
kita sangat berkemungkinan untuk mendapatkan semula s, dan itulah cara algoritma Simon menyelesaikan masalah Simon.
Tinggal satu perkara lagi yang perlu cakap tentang masalah Simon, dan ia berkaitan dengan kesukaran klasik masalah ini,
iaitu, berapa banyak query yang algoritma query klasik perlukan untuk menyelesaikan masalah Simon?
Jawapannya ialah, banyak, secara umum.
Ada pernyataan tepat yang berbeza yang boleh dibuat tentang kesukaran klasik masalah ini, dan ini hanya salah satunya.
Kalau kita ada mana-mana algoritma query probabilistik dan algoritma tu membuat kurang daripada 2 pangkat n per 2 tolak 1, tolak 1 query,
jadi itu adalah bilangan query yang eksponen dalam n, maka algoritma tu akan gagal menyelesaikan masalah Simon,
dengan kebarangkalian sekurang-kurangnya separuh.
Kadang-kadang, membuktikan keputusan ketidakmungkinan seperti ini boleh sangat mencabar, tapi yang ini tak terlalu sukar untuk dibuktikan
melalui analisis probabilistik yang asas.
Saya tak akan buat itu dalam pelajaran video ini, dan saya hanya akan fokus kepada intuisi di sebaliknya.
Kita cuba mencari rentetan tersembunyi s, tapi selagi kita tak query fungsi pada dua rentetan yang mempunyai nilai output yang sama,
kita akan mendapat maklumat yang sangat terhad tentang s.
Pada dasarnya, semua yang kita pelajari ialah rentetan tersembunyi s bukan XOR eksklusif mana-mana dua rentetan berbeza yang kita dah query,
Dan kalau kita query fungsi pada kurang daripada bilangan query ini, masih ada banyak pilihan s
yang belum disingkirkan.
Ini bukan bukti formal, tapi itulah idea asasnya.
Jadi secara ringkasnya, algoritma Simon memberi kita kelebihan yang ketara kuantum berbanding algoritma klasik dalam model query.
Khususnya, algoritma Simon menyelesaikan masalah Simon dengan bilangan query yang linear dalam bilangan bit input n kepada fungsi kita,
manakala mana-mana algoritma klasik, walaupun yang probabilistik, perlu membuat bilangan query yang eksponen dalam n
untuk menyelesaikan masalah Simon dengan kebarangkalian kejayaan yang munasabah.
Memang betul bahawa masalah Simon adalah masalah yang agak buatan yang diandaikan tiada sesiapa yang benar-benar nak selesaikan,
tapi itu kedua. Kadang-kadang idea perlu dikembangkan sebelum ia diamalkan.
Dan memang, Peter Shor telah dengan jelas menyatakan bahawa algoritma Simon itulah yang menginspirasi algoritma kuantumnya yang kini terkenal
untuk pemfaktoran integer, yang akan kita tengok dalam beberapa pelajaran lagi.
Dan itulah penghujung Pelajaran 5.
Dalam pelajaran ini, kita dah tengok model query pengiraan, dan kita dah nampak perkembangan contoh
algoritma kuantum yang menunjukkan kelebihan berbanding algoritma klasik dalam model ini.
Sebenarnya, masih banyak lagi yang diketahui tentang model query dan algoritma kuantum untuk masalah lain yang tak saya bincang.
Jadi kalau kita rasa model ini menarik, masih ada banyak lagi yang boleh dipelajari tentangnya.
Langkah seterusnya kita adalah untuk beralih dari model query dan menuju model pengiraan yang lebih mewakili
jenis masalah yang kita mungkin harap untuk selesaikan dalam praktik.
Saya harap kita akan bersama untuk Pelajaran 6, di mana kita akan fokus terutamanya pada meletakkan asas untuk mengkaji algoritma kuantum.
Dan dari sana, kita akan beralih kepada beberapa algoritma kuantum khusus, termasuk algoritma Shor untuk pemfaktoran integer
dalam pelajaran-pelajaran seterusnya. Selamat tinggal sehingga nanti!